Dude, have you played around with cursor?
I've been using cursor to write an app.
Dude, it is unreal, is it not?
It's pretty interesting.
So.
I did, dude, why do you guys say it like that, right?
As I think it's in my coffee.
Hey guys, our sponsor, Project Discovery, has dropped a new tool in collaboration with
Google's own Mandiant team called TLD Finder.
Okay, picture the sub finder, but for top level domains.
Need I say any more?
Check it out.
Dude, you're just rolling up to Twitter like, all right, guys, I'm freaking expensing these
Desheen Impact pies, dude.
What a tweet, man.
What a tweet.
Listen, listen, it's in policy, okay?
I get a per diem for dinner.
I chose to spend it at McDonald's, okay?
I open the McDonald's app and there's Genshin Impact apple pies.
How do you say no to that?
I was like, I ordered them and I was like, damn, I just realized I'm going to have to
file an itemized expense report for the Genshin Impact apple pies.
Oh my God, that's amazing.
That's amazing.
I'm looking at this little side picture here in Riverside where it shows, I think the thumbnail,
the first frame that happens when you loaded up your camera, dude.
It looks like you just rolled out of bed in your hair.
Okay.
All right, guys.
Sorry about all that.
Okay.
Joel, where are you at, man?
I'm in LA.
You're in LA.
Yeah.
I'm in LA for a couple of days.
I'm here for a conference.
Nice.
I'm just popping in and out.
But yeah, we're back on that East Coast, West Coast time difference.
Yeah.
It works out well, to be honest, because you're an early bird.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
It's not too bad, but it was a little bit difficult getting myself out of bed this morning.
I will say.
I'll say it works out well for me.
You're like, ah, 8 a.m.
I'm like, oh, 5 a.m.
5 a.m.
Oh, my gosh.
That's great, dude.
Well, yeah.
Just to give Joel an out here, there was a little bit of miscommunication this week,
and Joel did not know that he was going to be on the pod this week.
So, Joel, thank you for showing up, man.
You ready to record tomorrow?
And I was like, uh, no.
So, thanks for showing up, dude.
Thanks for doing the homework, and you got the rocking the AirPods today.
So, if this is your first episode, whoever is listening, I'm sorry.
This is not our normal audio quality, but, you know, we show up.
One thing I will say.
There was a rumor.
I don't know if this is true or, like, when it's going to happen, but apparently Apple's
going to be rolling out a change at some point where the AirPods are no longer going to switch
into handset mode when you're using the microphone, and they'll stay on, like, the 48 kilohertz
or whatever.
And I think it's going to happen, like, over thread or something.
What does that mean?
So, normally, like, your headphones, like, you know how, like, there's an audio quality
difference when you hop onto a call?
Yeah.
It's because it's using both the microphone and it's using both input and output, so it
runs at a lower bit rate.
Oh.
And so that's, like, why it sounds like shit, where if you set the, like, if I set it to
only use the audio and to use the microphone from my laptop, it'll switch back to sounding
good.
So, Apple's apparently making a change where they're going to make it so the AirPods can
do both without needing to switch quality.
That's pretty ballast now.
But I don't know.
We'll see.
We'll see, man.
I saw a tweet about that a couple weeks ago.
I said yes, but I've never used AirPods in my life, so I have no idea what you were talking
about.
Yeah.
I've heard that they're pretty decent.
I'm a pretty big fan.
I actually just bought, well, I have mixed experiences.
My Max's, I just had them break.
And thankfully, they were under AppleCare and they fixed them very quickly.
But during that process, I then had to buy a new pair of Pros, the little tiny ones.
And I've had a pair of Pros for a while and I'm quite happy with them because I like to
throw them in my pocket.
It's just like, I lose headphones so fast too.
I don't know what it is.
Like, I'm not a particularly irresponsible person when it comes to like keeping things,
like I never lose my wallet, my phone, my keys.
But for some reason, headphones are just not important to me.
Like, and I just, and it's, I mean, I just always get these like same $40 pair, you know,
because it's, you get a good enough quality where it's like, okay, this is good quality.
But if I lose it, it's not like, oh, this hurts.
You know?
That's interesting.
No, I love them because I just throw them in my pocket and I have them with me like everywhere
I go.
Yeah.
So.
Well, shout out to Ben for all the AirPods that he's lost.
We, we know that that's a legacy of his.
All right.
So I meant to start out this episode a little bit differently, Joel, but I'll do a little
story time.
Dude, I saw this story and I got some questions, but I'm going to let you go ahead.
Dude, this is, this is just the hacker mentality.
Okay.
I think this is the, I just wanted to do, I just wanted to share this story so that we
can talk about the struggle that hackers feel internally, ethical hackers, right?
Because I'm, I'm, I'm driving down.
Actually, I'm not driving.
I'm sitting in the passenger seat.
I almost always drive our, our car when Mariah and I are together.
Right.
But for some reason this time Mariah's driving and this asshole cuts her off completely.
And like, she has to slam on the brakes and she, and I'm looking at this person.
I was like, I can see this license plate very clearly.
Right.
I'm like, man, wouldn't it be cool if I like, like if I could just pick a couple black hat
things to do, how sick would it be to just be able to hand out like road retribution
for all of these like terrible sins that people commit while driving.
Right.
So I could just say like, that guy is going to get like, like a ton of toll fines or something
like that.
Right.
And just like, you need to work for the department of transportation.
I'd never do it.
I'm, I'm purely on the white hat side, but how cool would that be to just be able to
be like, I got your license plate number.
You're done for buddy.
You're done for.
You're done, bud.
All right.
You're not that guy, pal.
You know, and I know I'm not going to shout out any hackers in particular, but I know a
couple of hackers that have like some automation frameworks surrounding license plate numbers
and stuff like that.
Yeah.
I know the same one you're talking about.
I'm glad you phrased it that way because I wasn't going to call them out by names.
Yeah.
But, but, uh, you know, it would be cool if there was some way to, you know, if it wasn't
just read, if it was right, you know, if we could, if we could just be like, you, you
deserve fine.
You're going to get fined.
So, uh, maybe it's time to do an ethical hacking endeavor on the DMV.
Yeah.
I don't know, man.
Well, it's, it's not.
And the thing is, man, I'm not a particularly road ragey person.
So I figured I'd share this on the pod because it surprised me a little bit.
I'm like, why, why do I want to do that?
You know, like, and I think it's because they cut off Mariah, you know, every once in a
while it happens to me.
I get, I get a little, I get a, I get a road rage incident.
Well, incident, maybe that's not the right way to phrase it.
I'm not like getting out of my car and yelling at someone.
Um, usually it's the other way around.
Oh my gosh.
But it's not because I've caused anything.
It's because like, I'll flip them off and then they'll flip me back off.
And then it just escalates.
Dude, whenever anybody flips me off, I just, I do, I do this.
I do a little, I do a little heart side.
I do the heart back.
That's crazy.
That just gets them.
That gets them.
That's crazy.
If you flip them off, like they're like, oh, well screw that guy.
You know, he split me off.
I flipped him off.
But if you give them the heart and if you hit them with the little Korean drama heart,
then they're like, like, what is this?
What is wrong with, you know, it gets in their head a little bit more.
Right.
You know, am I wrong?
I'm not wrong.
Yeah, man.
That's super intimidating.
You're right.
Uh, I feel threatened.
Yeah.
You're welcome for that.
Um, all right, dude.
Yeah.
Well, we'll, we'll leave that.
We'll leave that at that.
Um, but so let's, let's, let's hit some of these topics.
We got, we got a pretty lean episode today, guys.
I'm, uh, I'm just coming off a live hacking event.
The, um, the show and tells were just like an hour ago.
So I am feeling a little bit high from those because it's always amazing to see what the other
hackers, um, come up with.
And I will also give a shout out to, uh, to Cosmin.
And I have it or 181 because him and I both there in this live hacking event that we're
working on, there's a massive scope.
Massive.
And him and I both happened to coincidentally choose the same little minimal application.
That was just a small part of a small part of the scope.
Right.
And just went ham on that for the whole live hacking event.
And, um, we both found 15 plus bugs.
Um, Cosmin's substantially more critical than mine, but we didn't dupe at all.
Isn't that amazing?
I was going to ask.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
And it, and it just, it blows the mind a little bit because like Cosmin, Cosmin and I, you
know, we, we've had vuln overlap before, but it just, cause I remember getting to the end
of this event just a couple of days ago and just being like, wow, I think I found everything
that could be possibly found on this app.
You know, I know everything about this app.
Like ain't nobody can teach me nothing about this app.
And then Cosmin comes in there with like six crits.
You know?
Yeah.
Then the professor walks in.
Seriously.
And I'm like, and he just found some way to get around a core protection and it just
unlocked a bunch of new scope.
Nice.
That's cool.
Yeah.
It just goes to show, man.
Even if you, you know, I preach a lot on the pod about going deep and becoming the world
expert on an application.
Right.
And, and, you know, I'm going to say, I thought I did it, you know, at this event, but there's
always more to learn about it, man.
There's always more to learn about it.
I've been para-hacking on a couple of different random like public programs.
Yeah.
And, uh, and we've been duping like crazy.
Oh no.
I like the, I like stuff that like we shouldn't be duping on either.
And it's like, we're duping by like two days and it's like super annoying.
Um, and like, I've never had this many dupes before.
Like I never dupe at live hacking events ever.
Yeah.
And like, uh, this time around I am.
Are you duping with your pair?
Like with the person you're working on it with or?
Yeah.
We're, we're collabing.
So we're, we're duping on like random people.
You're duping on somebody else.
Yeah.
Somebody else.
That's super annoying.
And it's close to, it's not like something that the program like lets it for.
Like there was one, there was one, I was talking about this in the discord that like, uh, originally
it was duped by like two years and I was like, okay, that's super annoying.
Like that this was open for two years.
And then like they reopened and they were like, oh, actually no, no, no, no.
This isn't a dupe.
And then like a couple of days later they duped it again on a different bug.
That was two days before.
Oh my gosh.
I was like, dang.
Dude.
Can't win here.
So, so demotivating.
I don't understand, you know, like I understand that they have to do that.
Right.
I understand that it's a part of their job to go in and be like, ah, actually this is a
dupe.
But like, if you do something like that where you open up and you undupe it and then you
re dupe it again a couple of days later, like you got to understand if you have any empathy,
you got to understand what that does to the hacker.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean, it's terribly demotivating.
Yeah.
So I don't know, man.
I did get a little bit of a shot in the gut though.
When I, when I thought I had really like, uh, wrecked this application and then Cosmin
comes in there with like six crits.
Do you feel like the bypass that he found was something you would have found?
No.
I mean, it was, I mean, so I think I would have found it eventually, but the thing is I
specifically decided to ignore, um, a certain part of the application because I thought that
the impact was not going to be, uh, I'll just be a little bit more clear about it.
Um, I, I decided to ignore.
Because I'm like, you know what?
The impact here is a little bit low.
I kind of want to go for the, for the juicy juice.
Right.
Yeah.
Um, yeah.
And, and, um, and so I, I ignored that part and I, there was an additional piece of impact
that could be achieved by using a different component.
Um, within that environment.
So I might, I might have to bleep some of that.
We'll see.
It's hard.
Sorry if I do guys, but, um, yeah, it was, it was a very, it was a very creative approach.
And I think, you know, at the end of the day, he just knew more about that part of the application
than I did.
And that's because I didn't go as deep as I could have.
And that's the thing that I love about these life hacking events, man, is you always get
to see how the other hackers minds work and you get to fine tune your own hacker intuition
and your own, you know, brain radar there.
Um, and, and then next time, you know, next time I'm going to be a little bit more thorough
about this for sure.
Nice.
Hell yeah, dude.
That's awesome.
Yo, y'all exciting announcement real quick.
We are finally launching the CTBB podcast swag store.
Yeah, that's right.
The shirts that Joel and I have been wearing on the pod for the past couple months will
finally be available for y'all to purchase at ctbb.show slash swag.
We gave out quite a few of them at DEF CON, but if you didn't get your hands on one, or maybe
you want some more, then definitely check out the swag store.
Also, if you're a critical thinker on discord, then check the discord channel because you'll
have a discount code available for you there.
Or maybe this is a good opportunity for you to sign up and become a critical thinker if
you're not already, because you'll get a great discount on the swag.
Um, if you do so.
All right, cool.
I think that's a wrap.
Uh, anything else I need to tell you about that?
I don't think so.
All right, cool.
Back to the pod.
Let's go.
All right.
So, um, we got a couple of things.
We got a couple of write-ups.
We got a couple of gadgets.
Uh, we got some cool research that I, that I stumbled upon, but first I wanted to go ahead
and handle a, uh, a community request here from NBK underscore 2000 on Twitter saying,
tell us about some of the stuff you're doing with cursor.
Uh, after I tweeted about cursor, dude, have you played around with cursor?
I've been using cursor to write an app.
Dude, it is unreal.
Is it not?
It's pretty interesting.
Um, so.
I did.
Dude, why do you guys say it like that?
Right.
Is it like taking a sip of my coffee?
Um, yeah.
So I've, I've, I've been, I used it quite a bit, uh, over the last couple of weeks.
Um, the thing is it can be really good for certain things.
Um, I think a lot of the hype around it was very misleading.
Uh, wow.
Okay.
We're going to have different takes on this.
Go, go, go for it.
You're an actual dev.
So maybe.
And, and, and, and for what it's worth, for what it's worth, I've been using it to write
a complicated iOS app for the last couple of weeks.
Um, so it's not like I'm like, I'm not experienced with it.
Um, I've, I've gone back and forth with it quite a bit and I'm now at the point where I'm
like fully not using it.
Uh, I actually uninstalled it the other day because I'm now like, I'm just on manual development
and I'll explain it a little bit why, but, um, cursor.
So, so early on when I, when I first saw it, like a lot of the hype being drummed up,
they were like, check this thing out.
There's cursor composer.
You just give it this MD file.
Like you, you know, describe like how you want your backend app to work and whatever.
And then, uh, you just feed it into this and it'll go and create it.
And I was like, wow, that's pretty cool.
Um, so I went and I was testing with it and I was like, oh, you know, you can, you can
actually do this.
But I was having trouble like replicating those results to the same extent until I started
taking a closer look at those demo videos.
And when you look at the demo videos, um, the markdown file that they provided to, to
cursor and the demo was create a file called server.ts with the following content.
And it's literally just a code block.
And like, they wrote the code for it.
That's not like, so that doesn't make any sense at all.
So, so that aside, right?
Like taking that with a grain of salt, like the fact that it can actually get close.
Pretty cool.
Um, you know, like it's very interesting technology.
Um, you know, I think like the context stuff is probably where the biggest hurdle is.
Like there's just so much context where you get to a point, and this is why I've switched
to manual development where there's too much context for a GPT, um, especially a free one
to be able to do anything meaningful with.
And you'll get to a point where it starts to clobber itself, where it'll, you know, change
things or it doesn't have enough context to, to keep things the way they are, to keep functionality
the same.
And like, as a human, like, you know, like, I don't want to change this.
I just want to add this one thing, but it will like change other parts of the application
just to do this one thing.
Or it'll, you know, re-add a class that already exists, even though it should know that it
exists, um, just for like, you know, to get rid of an error message.
Yeah.
Um, so, so it'll do like a lot of that kind of stuff, which is a little bit tricky.
Um, but, um, you know, as a whole, it's a very, very cool piece of software.
Yeah.
And so, so I think you're coming, I think our difference in perspective here is, is coming
from the fact that you're using it to actually code a large application, right?
The, the project you're working on is a lot more advanced than anything I'm working on.
Right.
And it's also in, in a language I think that, that probably I, I theorize the, the AI has
less experience with, um, for me, I'm writing mostly HTML, CSS, JavaScript, Python, right?
Those are, those are the ones that I'm using it for.
And yeah.
And I'm most of the time what I'm coding are proof of concept exploits.
Right.
So I'll, I'll essentially say to it, like, and I'll have like cool ideas for this is, this
is the cool part, right?
Because for, for a hacker, like I, I often have these cool ideas for my proof of concept
bugs, especially my web stuff that kind of, um, utilizes common flows of the web and like,
uh, you know, a user's tendency to be able to, or to wait on a page, you know, for a certain
amount of time, right.
Without realizing anything's happening.
So I can say like, Hey, generate a, a loading bar that takes, you know, 20 seconds for it to
load.
And, and if I had to code that myself, I'd be like, I'm not going to do that, but because
I can just tell cursor, Hey, generate that.
And it does it.
It makes my proof of concepts much more beautiful and much more realistic to the program where
they can come to this page and be like, Oh yeah, I didn't even realize I was sitting on
this page for 20 seconds.
Um, and something's happening in the background.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
So, so before I was actually having it right.
An iOS app.
Um, uh, a lot of the experimentation I was doing with it was around like web apps and
stuff.
Yeah.
Um, and just having like, I won't go into the rabbit hole.
It's a, it's a very dumb rabbit hole, but we were trying to have it right.
A very silly web app.
Um, I can't even go into the details.
I guess it's too much, but, um, the point is, uh, it, it, it can do a lot of really impressive
stuff.
I think one of the more impressive things is how it can integrate with libraries.
So you'll be like, you know, I want, I want to do this thing.
And instead of like expecting that it's going to home roll, like image recognition or something,
it'll just pull some JavaScript library that actually does it really well.
And it'll just implement it and it just works.
Um, so, you know, there were definitely like for, for more basic web apps, it's really good
at that kind of stuff.
And like, you know, a couple files, like you said, like, you know, maybe you need a backend
server that does some specific flow and you just want like a little front end, like an
HTML thing that, you know, and could you do it yourself?
Sure.
But can you do it in 10 seconds?
No.
So exactly.
You know, cursor is kind of nice for that.
Here's, here's the thing that I'll, I'll, I'll shout out about cursor to the hackers out
there.
Like for us, the end goal is not to create some majestic code that is running very high
efficiency, very optimized.
Well, speak for yourself.
Okay.
Well, most of the, most of the time when we're, you know, coding our proof of concepts.
I'm trying to make a million bucks with my iOS app.
Hey, no, I mean, you're, you're, you're Devin.
I'm talking about us as hackers, right?
Um, you know, most of the time our, our goal is to just build POCs.
This thing is a very good for getting a rough, a rough solution to a problem.
And, uh, and also adding some of those nice to haves that, that make it a lot more clear.
For example, I'll just share this little tidbit.
One of the things that, um, is really negative about, um, GDPR and, and all of these like cookie
stuff.
Like we got to accept the cookies is that everybody is just a tune, tuned to that out
completely.
So it is extremely easy to harvest a click by just popping up a little boxing.
Like, do you like cookies?
You don't even need to say anything else.
Just say cookies.
They're just like, accept, accept, accept.
Right.
So it's extremely easy to harvest a click in that, in that scenario.
Um, and, and so, uh, you know, in order to make your proof of concepts more reasonable,
more beautiful, more convincing to the team, which we've already talked about can,
you know, really increase your bounty.
I think, uh, my experience has been up to 1.5 times your bounty.
If you do a really well, good.
Let me just throw a little anecdote in here.
I woke up this morning and I checked my email inbox and, um, I had a beautiful POC.
Okay.
For the record.
Like I said, I've been going deep on, on some applications.
We went through the effort of writing an entire backend server to handle and proxy your class,
all this stuff.
Okay.
I get a notification this morning.
I mean, 3-Header has updated severity from critical 9.02 none.
No, Joel, please.
Okay.
Report has transitioned into pending program review.
Dude, you know, we do have a little bit of, of like good cop, bad cop thing going on
here with bug bounty.
Cause I feel like I'm relentlessly optimistic about bug bounty.
And I'm like, this is the great shit about bug bounty.
I love getting dupes so I can see where I, where I messed up.
And I'm like, I, when I get a dupe, I want to quit hacking.
Oh my God, dude.
I love it, man.
Yeah.
No, I mean, I, I, and not to say it's always the case, but using cursor AI to, to TLDR it
for anybody who didn't follow us through that monstrosity of a conversation.
Cursor is really good for building POCs that have nice, nice to haves, especially in the
web world.
Um, and also just making quick modifications to your code.
Um, so you don't have to go look up all these things because us as hackers, we're not necessarily
writing the code every day.
We're reading the code.
We're playing around with it.
Um, and we can get it there.
It just takes more time.
I think cursor is an excellent tool for hackers because it takes away that, that, um, need
to know all the syntax, all the flows.
And it does a lot of it.
If you can describe the general concept.
Right.
For sure.
Like it definitely, and like I said, it doesn't have to be, I think.
Like, you know, unfortunately when, when there's hype, clearly that video that I was talking
about, like, you know, they want it to work perfectly.
So that's why it was done in the way that it does.
That it does.
So they can say, you know, write the backend for this app using this file.
And it just, just works, right.
Quote unquote, just works.
But, but like, it just works because you did all the heavy lifting.
That being said, you can also get it to do that stuff.
Right.
And, and it can do a good amount of work and pull in a lot of context.
Just out of the box, like free using cloud 3.5.
Like, you know, very, very, you know, it's very cool.
Very, very interesting stuff.
I honestly, the biggest thing that I like struggle with is I pay for chat GPT premium or plus
or whatever.
And I have like access to O1 preview and stuff.
I just want to hook it into that.
And I don't want to pay for like the API stuff, which is like a totally different.
Because it's like tokens and stuff.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I do.
I mean, do you think it's better?
Do you think like opening?
I don't know.
I mean, here's the thing.
Here's the thing.
Whether or not it's better.
I'm unsure.
The fact that I'm paying for it is really all it is.
So like I'm paying for a version that should be better than cloud 3.5 out of the box.
You know, I think that I think that the the cloud products are probably better for code
stuff.
And I that's that's what I've heard from people that know more about AI than me.
So that's what I've heard as well.
But I've gone back and forth with the two of them.
I think the biggest.
Well, to be fair, I put it up on very, very difficult, unfair challenges where I'll be
like generate a free to script and it'll start to hallucinate.
And I'm like, man, this stuff is garbage.
And then I'll be like generate a Python script that like opens a Web server and do that perfectly.
And obviously, you know, so yeah, I think it depends on, you know, set your expectations
accordingly.
But it's still it's still quite cool.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I've got this next item here on the doc, Joel, and I'm going to I'm going to talk through
it really quick, but I'm also going to go off on a little bit of a tangent.
Okay.
From a from a recent hacking.
You never do that.
So and neither do I.
So I'm just cautioning you, you know, so you're not taken by surprise.
You know, given our normal strict adherence to the doc.
Right.
Okay.
So we got a write up here from Cincinnati from summoning team.
He was on the pod a couple months ago.
And it's a great write up on what's up gold SQL.
I the thing that I wanted to highlight from this and we'll link it down below.
I'm not going to walk you through the whole thing.
Once again, because like, like Senna does, it's an amazing detailed write up of all the
different code blocks and and all the different techniques and thought patterns that that he
went through.
So definitely a recommended read.
I just want to pull a couple things out of this.
Okay.
So he gets a vanilla SQL I and I want to just say there's like this really bad ass.
A vanilla SQL I.
No, just like.
First of all, I haven't found a SQL injection since 2015.
But keep going.
I know.
Right.
This is crazy, dude.
Like they exist.
They can find them.
There's been a couple.
It's been literally almost 10 years that they've had a SQL injection.
I know.
Like they're deep in there.
How are we not using prepared statements folks?
Come on, dude.
And this is what he said.
I'm just going to quote this thing.
He says, and this leads to a vanilla SQL injection as one would expect from such a sophisticated
application.
Yeah.
One burned.
Two.
Great bug.
So not very good.
Wait.
Real quick.
Yeah.
I need to pivot back to the cursor stuff because this reminded me of something.
What are you doing?
That video I was talking about, I quote tweeted it when I first saw it.
And I was like security engineers or security researchers rubbing their hands together.
The dev develops an entire backend service without knowing how it works.
This is exactly how I feel, dude.
Like, you know, it's like you got this awesome, sophisticated application secretly behind the
scenes.
Cursor, Claude 3.5 wrote this whole thing and it did it in a way because it's like, I want
to do this fast and quick and it's just going to work.
And it accidentally created like 15 security vulnerabilities behind the scenes, but it works.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
I think it's great job security for us.
As long as there isn't a, you know, cursor equivalent of the security research.
We need to land some AI sponsors here.
Job security.
I'm seeing it now.
Yeah, absolutely.
Okay.
So now that you've gone off on your little tangent, we're going back to the thing.
We got an SQL I.
Here's what he does with this.
Okay.
He, what he ends up doing is a common SQL I exploitation technique, which is let me overwrite
the master password for this application.
Right.
So I can just log in as the admin and, and get into the app.
But in this specific application, this master password is encrypted.
Okay.
And so it's, it's not as easy as just overwriting the password and you can't register an account
or anything.
This is an unauth bug.
So, so what does he do?
Um, he dives deep into the encryption, figures out exactly how it works and you can't reproduce
it.
You know, it's unique to a random thing on the, on that machine.
Right.
But what he does instead is he finds an encryption Oracle.
Okay.
And he uses the SQL I to read a, an encrypted piece of text from somewhere else in the application
that's in the database, extract that out and set it as the master password for the, um,
for the actual user and then proceeds to log in.
Right.
So I just want to, one thing I will say is like, this is one of those, like you get to
this point and you're like, okay, how bad do I want to destroy this application?
Because, uh, I'm going to test some things that are probably going to break everything.
Yes.
Yeah.
No, no.
And, and, you know, this is, it's important to notice a note here that, that he's, he's
targeting an application that is offline.
Right.
This is a, this is not a cloud instance.
This is a, you know, this is him on his machine with his thing, you know, don't go overriding
all this stuff with SQL injections.
It's extremely dangerous.
And I've been burned by it.
Tons of people have been burned by it.
So please don't do that in production.
But, um, I think that this was a really unique, um, cool thing to do.
And I, I, I wanted to sort of pivot off of the topic a little bit because this whole concept
of encryption oracles, um, it's very interesting and it's very applicable, I think.
So, um, there's an app that I've been testing a couple months ago where there's a big piece
of their security was built off of this encryption aspect that they had.
And, um, and if you were able to get around that encryption, um, you could really reliably
attack the application.
Um, and, and so, which I think is pretty common by the way.
Yeah.
Like, um, just like, you know, JWTs, for example, I think like a great example where like a JWT
is one key leak or one generation Oracle or one arbitrary input in like JSON injection,
like anything like from being really catastrophic.
Right.
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
And, and, and so I think a lot of hackers sort of shy away from this cryptography piece because
it's very math heavy and it's very like complex and you've got to understand a lot of the various
pieces of the system to be able to exploit it.
But, um, it's extremely impactful.
And one of the ones, one of the attacks that I think is really, um, consistently impactful
if you can figure it out is this Oracle thing, right?
If you can provide some, some string and that string will get encrypted reliably and you can
get that encrypted value out.
Yep.
There's a lot of weird stuff you can do with that because applications are not trusting
or they're, they're, they're not expecting that you can get that encrypted value.
Right.
And, and so they're, they're trusting that.
And, um, and so anytime you see something, something like that, just.
Like brainstorm a little bit in your brain.
Like, how could I get this?
How could I get this encrypted value?
Where could I, where could I find this?
And then actually what I did in a specific environment was I set up a, um, a Heido workflow
that took like, you know, maybe 15 minutes to write where, um, I would inject at a specific
spot.
I'll, I'll keep it to a little vague.
I'll, I'll inject at a specific spot and then note, you know, where that, uh, I could tell
in the response, whether or not my, my data had been encrypted and put in the response
or not.
Um, and, and so I think that that sort of thing, uh, is, and then I navigated the application,
navigated that, but it didn't end up paying out.
But, uh, I was proud of the methodology because I think there are very niche cases where you
can get that, that encryption Oracle and then apply it to the app.
And it's really catastrophic.
Yeah.
So I've got, I've got two tips on that.
One is, um, if you think that you have one, uh, try to pad in your data with like something
like a super, super long string, like, you know, a thousand A's or something.
And one common thing that you'll see is, you know, the response length goes up significantly
when you have that encryption Oracle, like, you know, the value is getting reflected in
there.
Um, the other thing is with, with the length side of it, a lot of applications aren't expecting
large, like, you know, very large JSON objects and stuff.
Yeah.
And so, um, yeah, there's definitely inflating the size.
If you theorize that you might be able to do a lot of things, you know, like, you know,
the library level where it might be trying to craft the JWT or trying to craft, um, you
know, that response token back, uh, that it's generating for you that encryption token.
Um, so yeah.
Yeah.
Large values is, is really useful.
That, that length piece was exactly one of the, uh, one of the techniques I used in that
application.
Um, and so, yeah, there's definitely inflating the size.
If you theorize that you might be injecting into an encrypted context, then just inflate
your input size.
And if the output is also inflated, then there's a good chance that you're injecting somewhere
in that.
Um, and you might be able to, you know, depending on what's being encrypted, you know, you could,
you could do, you know, JSON injection, you could do path traversals, you could do, you
know, a lot, all sorts of stuff.
Um, and this is one of my favorite things to do, you know, for like information gathering
when I'm looking at an application, it's just like fuzzy inputs with different types and different
things and what it's expecting.
So if it's expecting a string, give it a list, uh, or give it null.
If it's like a JSON, like give it, uh, you know, uh, the, the, the null type, not, not an
empty string.
Um, give it like extra parameters, give it invalid JSON, just try a bunch of different stuff
because eventually one of those is going to raise an error and it's going to give you
something that's a bit revealing about the application about how it's, how it's actually
functioning.
Yeah.
Dude.
I, um, when you said that, it made me think of something.
I don't know if you were asleep or not.
Cause I know the time zones didn't work super well for you, but there was a, um, there was
a show and tell.
I didn't see it.
I should say there was a show and tell given.
And let's just say Franz was wearing a CTVB t-shirt and there was a shout out given to CTVB
podcast for something that has been said in the history of the podcast that may have had an
application.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Hmm.
All right, man.
Let's, uh, let's move along here.
So, uh, one of the things that I've been hacking on lately, um, there was an ability for, for me
to do a file upload.
Um, and in, inside of this file upload environment, um, there was essentially a regex for the, the
content type that, that of the file that you could upload.
Um, and I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I,
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I
And then you've also got a super useful gadget from YouTube.
And this is a redirect chain that will allow you to go from www.youtube.com, which is often used for embedding YouTube videos.
In the write-up, they do a path traversal on embedding YouTube videos.
So I could see this being very useful in other environments as well.
And you land on, you can land on a Google Docs site, but you can also land on www.google.com,
which we all know if we've listened to the podcast, has an open redirect via the slash amp
endpoint to get you out.
So I've got a, I've got a, a URL that I'll put in the notes for this episode that starts with www.youtube.com
and will end on my attacker control domain.
And I can see this being extremely helpful for, for client side chains, very similar to the one in this,
in this report.
And also for anything that is trying to parse a YouTube video, you might even be able,
if it's following redirects, you might even be able to get an SSRF out of this.
Um, so definitely, definitely some impact, impact there.
Um, just, I realized we got a little distracted.
The actual, um, the, the exploit that this person comes up with in the end is, you know, they, they're sharing the whole, I did say that.
Okay.
That's good.
The, the whole Google drive.
Um, and, and so there's lots of really cool tips adjacent to that, um, in this write-up as well.
Um, and then let me, let me go ahead and grab one more thing out of here that I had.
Um, okay.
Yeah.
I remember what it is.
Dude, did you see, did you see at the end of this write-up?
I'm just going to read a quote from this.
Everything on this page is just HTML and CSS crafted with love, no images, no JavaScript or other resources.
And it's all G zipped into 31 kilobytes.
So this whole write-up click on the link, dude.
There's like, it looks like there's a bunch of, um, images from like Google drive in here.
None of these are images.
This is all this, this lunatic of a person wrote all of this in HTML and CSS only.
No JavaScript even.
Bro, what the fuck?
So like there, there are pictures throughout this whole write-up.
And if you click on them, you can like select all the text.
These are like, I can undo and redo the checkbox and type in.
Right.
It's crazy, right?
What is this?
It's nuts.
It's crazy.
It's very, very cool.
So, um, kind of a shout out to them.
Like lira.horse, um, is a really cool blog.
And I went to go read a little bit more about this.
And they have another, um, article called stealing your Telegram account in 10 seconds flat.
And I was like, okay, what's going on here?
And essentially it outlines an exploit that they weren't able to fully develop.
But essentially when you send a message in Telegram that contains a specific domain in it,
it will attach the send, like the, the, the person's credentials who is receiving that,
that domain to the link.
So you click on it and you're automatically authed into the domain, um, for Telegram related,
like short links and stuff like that.
Um, so one, if you're a Telegram hacker, cause I know they have a bug bounty program,
uh, suss that very thoroughly.
Cause that is super sketchy.
And, um, and also it, it, they outlined a very cool attack vector, which is like,
if you send a message to somebody and you have their phone, you can get persistent access
on their phone by clicking that link.
And then just changing the URL up at the top of the browser very quickly to a URL that you
control and it contains their auth token in it.
And you're just very easily able to hijack their account in like sub 10 seconds.
Um, so I think that was, I thought that was a really cool writeup.
I don't think they got a bounty for it.
I don't know that they even submitted it, but I think that kind of attack vector is,
I think that kind of functionality is not something you really want to have in your application.
So, um, you know, whether it be a low or a medium, I would have, I would have still
reported that, I think.
Yeah.
I mean, that's, that's super crazy.
That's, uh, that's a really interesting insight that I didn't actually realize.
Yeah.
Especially, especially when it's an application like Telegram, which claims to be like super,
super secure and security oriented.
Right.
Um, to have something like that, I think is really not a great idea.
Definitely going to get yourself pwned somehow with that.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Um, all right, man, Joel, that's all I had on the doc for today.
You got anything, anything else before we wrap it up?
Or is that the pod?
Yeah.
I think that's a, I think that's the pod.
I got a lot of juicy notes.
I got to make sure I'm getting all my plugins from the plugin store.
Yeah.
I got to look at some content type injection.
So hell yeah, man.
This is, this is good stuff.
Good episode, dude.
All right.
That's the pod.
Peace.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for listening.
And if you want more critical thinking content, head over to ctbb.show slash discord.
Join the discord.
There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there.
And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you
access to masterclasses, AMAs, hack alongs, exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel
with us.
We'll see you there.